mais d'abord donc la corse et ce mot qui
peut peut-être tout changer autonomy
pierre-henri vol durban
afin d'apaiser les tensions de ces
derniers jours le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin s'est rendu
à ajaccio après s'être dit prêt à
l'autonomie de la corse une annonce qui
ouvre donc la porte aux discussions
c'est le moment je crois il ya eu cette
tentative d'assassinât sur yon colonnes
il y a depuis plus de 10 jours
d'événements graves qui se passe en
corse et je veux d'ailleurs ce temps les
policiers les gendarmes une soixantaine
ont été blessées et des bâtiments
publics ont été attaqués
c'est une première étape pour le
président autonomiste de corse pas
encore victoire ni pour moi ni pour le
peuple corse c'est important que le
ministre de l'intérieur au nom du
premier ministre est probablement dû du
président de la république dise
aujourd'hui publiquement que le
gouvernement et l'état sont prêts à
rentrer dans une discussion qui a
vocation à être historique l'agression à
la prison d'arles par un autre détenu le
2 mars d' yvan colonna l'assassin du
préfet claude erignac a déclenché de
nombreuses manifestations qui ont
dégénéré en corse
face aux revendications et à son état de
santé le 8 mars dernier le gouvernement
met fin à son statut de détenu
particulièrement signalé alors qu yvan
colonna le demandait depuis plusieurs
années une décision vu comme une
provocation par ses proches et dénoncé
dans ce tweet par sa soeur trois jours
plus tard c'est au tour de deux autres
membres du commando erignac de se voir
retirer ce statut l'exécutif se défend
d'agir sous pression comme nous ne
cédons pas à pression de la rue il ne
peut avoir de rapprochement décidé par
le premier ministre que lorsque les
choses se seront calmées encore
lorsqu'il n'y aura pas de violences
urbaines et lorsque les bombes agricoles
auront arrêté le ministre de l'intérieur
a indiqué que le processus d'autonomie
était long et se dit prêt à définir un
calendrier pour une éventuelle évolution
législative de la corse le mouvement
indépendantiste flnc menace dans un
communiqué de reprendre la lutte et
dénonce le déni méprisant de l'état face
au peuple corse
la corse est elle en marche vers
l'autonomie on en débat tout de suite
avec rien de chemin grand reporter au
monde bonsoir bienvenue paul toussaint
parigi sénateur de haute corse bonsoir
vous êtes militant nationaliste membres
du groupe écologiste au sénat benjamin
morel bonsoir maître de conférences en
droit public à l'université paris ii
panthéon assas matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique
bonsoir mathieu merci d'être là nous
sommes prêts à aller jusqu'à l'autonomie
rien de chemin je commence avec vous
cette cette phrase du ministre de
l'intérieur dans son interview à corse
matin est ce qu'elle peut calmer la
colère de la rue d'après vous en tout
cas elle est surprenante c'est quand
même pas à vous qu'on avait l'habitude
d'entendre on a l'habitude des
discussions à vrai dire depuis 1982
depuis le statut joxe on a eu ensuite ça
je m'en souviens bien to look ce qu'on a
appelé le processus matignon lorsque
lionel jospin était premier ministre a
duré duré duré et puis au fond ça n'a
pas abouti si ça aboutit à une plus
grande une plus grande liberté pour la
collectivité de corse mais au fond à la
fin le conseil constitutionnel avait
retoqué le projet alors qu'ils n'avaient
même pas le mot autonomie d'eau c'est
vrai que c'est une surprise de voir ça à
la une de corse-matin je pense que les
corses on y tient il se passe quelque
chose
paul toussaint paris dit on a vu dans le
dans le reportage les images des
manifestations
violentes alors il ya il ya une première
lecture qui est de dire masse et une
prime à la violence finalement il a
fallu la violence pour que le
gouvernement lâche ça alors on peut voir
un peu les choses comme ça effectivement
le priva la violence effectivement après
quelques années de gestion de la
collectivité territoriale par les
nationalistes sous la présidence de
gilles simeoni président de l'exécutif
certain nombre de demandes ont été
faites à l'état c'est un nombre de
démarches aussi afin de afin de pouvoir
mettre en place un programme électoral
qui avait été annoncé haut et clair lors
des différentes campagnes électorales et
on s'aperçoit que en fait au bout de
cinq ans pas d'avancées et de
manifestations et occupations de la rue
a fait céder le gouvernement cette ce
mot autonomie parce qu'effectivement
rien le disais c'est pas la première
fois que ça vient dans le débat
politique est ce que cette fois-ci vous
y croyez
j'espère une chose c'est que deux
ministres vers man 1 ne soit venu avec
une valise où il n'y a pas seulement
qu'un mot à l'intérieur il ya aussi une
réflexion sur sur ce que peut être
l'autonomie de la corse vous avez bien
compris que la demande aujourd'hui de
l'exécutif de la corse mais aussi la
majorité territoriale dans son ensemble
c'est une autonomie pleine et entière ce
n'est pas une forte centralisation
aujourd'hui de forte centralisation ne
conviendrait pas à notre demande alors
on y reviendra et on en trouve un dans
le détail de ce que peut être une
autonomie pleine et entière si je puis
me permettre comme la différence par
rapport à 1990 et avant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la corsa les autonomies
celle vote à deux tiers oui autonomistes
1 et elle a quand même c'est une
élection dans un fauteuil pour gilles
simonet aux dernières régionales était
quasiment le meilleur élu tout du
continent est d'accord sur bien sûr
c'est une dimension très importante
benjamin morel bon ça prendra du temps
de toute façon il va falloir attendre
d'avoir passé la présidentielle
évidemment pour engager un processus
digne de ce nom quand vous avez réagi à
ce qu'ils ont été surpris de lire ce mot
dans l'interview de gérald darmanin
n'ont pas réellement parce qu'en réalité
l'objectif de gérald darmanin et en
effet de calmer aujourd'hui la situation
en corse et l'autonomie est en fait une
forme de fétiches on reviendra peut-être
plus précisément sur ce que ça signifie
mais juridiquement ça signifie en soit
on soit pas grand chose car on peut tous
moyens y mettre exactement ça signifie
se donner sa propre norme et si vous
regardez la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales à l'article
72 auquel sont astreints les communes
acceptera et bien c'est une forme
d'autonomie est-ce que c'est l'autonomie
telle qu'elle est envisagée par
l'article 312 c'est évidemment pas le
cas est ce que c'est une autonomie plus
large est ce que ça va jusqu'à l'article
74 l'article 74 avait des collectivités
type wallis et futuna ils sont incités
dans le temps dans l'article et la
question c'est est-ce qu on rajouterait
l'accord dans cet agrément mais wallis
et futuna par exemple savez qu'on a
encore des rois en france c'est à dire
quoi wallis et futuna venez pas de
communes vous avez trois rois donc on
est dans des statuts qui sont des
statuts très particulier en nouvelle
calédonie vous avez un statut qui est
visé comme étant coloniale dans les
accords de nouméa c'est à dire que c'est
un statut colonial le vraiment le statut
néo-calédonien avec la possibilité de
passer des traités à l'international
avec des territoires qui sont pas dans
l'euro qui sont francs pacifique
louvoyer entre la nouvelle calédonie et
l'article 72 et bien en réalité vous
avez tout un continuum et donc à partir
de là définir ce qu'est autonome et
c'est peut-être ça qui demain pourra
mettre le feu aux poudres parce qu'il
n'est pas certain 8 donc vous dites il
ya finalement le gouvernement et
emmanuel macron dalle points prennent un
risque ils prennent un risque parce
qu'en réalité je ne suis pas sûr que ce
qu'entendent aujourd'hui les
nationalistes en termes d'autonomie et
ce qu'entend gérald darmanin et bien ce
soit tout à fait la même chose et au
bout du compte lorsqu'il s'agira
vraiment de mettre un contenu à ce
moment là il n'est pas certain que les
esprits s'accordent une réaction ce
matin celle de la candidate elle est
valérie pécresse qui pointent la
faiblesse de l'état et du candidat
macron l'écoutent là aujourd'hui on a un
président qui visiblement aux abois aux
abois et qu'ils cèdent à la violence
comme il l'a fait à notre dame des
landes en ne respectant pas les
résultats du référendum et ça ça n'est
pas sain ça n'est pas sans il faut
ramener l'ordre en corse avant d'entamer
les négociations parce que sinon l'état
n'entamera pas ces négociations sur le
nouveau statut de la corse dans position
de force mathieu emmanuel macron préfère
donner le sentiment de céder à la rue
que le laisser la situation sans menu
est est ce que vous faites là tu
analyses oui ça c'est amusant parce que
c'est même la première fois qu'elle en
parle quasiment valérie pécresse ce
sujet de l'accord ça fait quand même
quinze jours qu'on a des émeutes après
l'agression 10 ans colonnes à la prison
d'arles personne ne s'en est saisie dans
la campagne présidentielle comme si
c'était quelque chose qu'on était sous
le tapis comme si au fond personne
n'avait rien à dire parce que personne
n'avait de solution il ya un une
situation qui est explosive encore c'est
un point de vue de de l'ordre public
devient aisé mais ce qu'on a vu les
cocktails molotov tous à une situation
politique qui est très compliqué je
parle trop de contrôles mais j'ai avec
un exécutif corse qui est quand même
affaiblie même s'il a été très très bien
et lui parce qu'il est temps sépare plus
nationaliste que que lui on le sait et
puis il ya surtout une situation
politique tout au long du quinquennat
qui a été au fond un long malentendu
entre emmanuel macron aux cantons qui
chez siemens et pro
dit on peut placer quelques uns de ses
espoirs au début du quinquennat et
aujourd'hui où les deux hommes sont en
situation quasiment deux ne se parlent
pas ils celui de ceux ci se sont pas
parlé depuis depuis longtemps et donc
tout ça fait une situation qui est sans
doute plus explosif qu'on a bien voulu
le voir uniquement à travers les images
des émeutes et ce geste là on y
reviendra moi moi c'est arrivé en
lâchant l'autonomie avant même d'engager
des discussions en réponse à des
manifestations qu'ils ne réclamaient
même pas forcément l'autonomie mais dont
les slogans étaient est un assassin
prisonniers politiques moi ça à la fois
ça me choque et ça m'étonne mai mais oui
c'est un geste évidemment du de
l'exécutif pour tenter de calmer de
calmer la situation et rien ne change
ensuite on va vraiment entrer dans le
détail de ce que pourrait être cette
autonomie même si on reste un peu sur le
l'impact politique d'une mesure où une
annonce comme celle là est ce que pour
autant sa garantie et monaco parce que
si je fais le raisonnement pour que
l'apport de l'autonomie reste ouverte il
faut qu'il soit réélu est ce que ça peut
lui garantir un vote des corses en sa
faveur alors d'abord je pense je suis
d'accord avec mathieu on a un peu parlé
politique comme on peut parler la presse
on a peu parlé mais je comprends aussi
pourquoi parce que pour avoir suivi ces
manifestations j'avais je vais faire un
petit avait eu une sorte de gêne
journalistique parce que je voyais ces
voix-là ces lycéens ces collégiens le
trajet visée qui faisait qu'y jouer à la
guerre un peu et la vraie guerre elle
n'était pas là elle était en ukraine et
je sais que moi même j'avais une sorte
de deux gènes a raconté ces
manifestations comme si oui je peux le
dire on était dans un tel décalage que
ça semblait absolument irréel je pense
aussi que c'est pour ça qu'on en a pas
tellement parler parce que évidemment
l'événement était ailleurs il était
mondiale alors surgit simeoni alors
surgi 6 min je pense pas qu'il soit il
est évidemment comme toujours on l'a
toujours une aile qui vous pousse à
aller un peu plus loin c'est le cas chez
son interventionnisme il a été quand
même réélu seul c'est à dire que la
première fois il avait fait alliance et
la seconde fois il a été réélu sial
d'eau qu'il est en position de force et
c'est vrai qu'au début avec emmanuel
macron on pouvait penser qu'il y aurait
une entente parce que ce sont deux
personnes qui ont été lus de manière un
peu disruptive c'était des générations
nouvelles
il y avait quelque chose qui pouvait se
faire qu'en et puis très vite on s'est
rendu compte quand même mais faut pas
oublier qu emmanuel macron il a commencé
à militer chez jean pierre chevènement
casting est plutôt un républicain est
donc la première fois qu'il vient en
corse je me souviens quand même 2 est
tellement génial il vit avec jean pierre
chevènement en france on se rend pas
tellement content enfin à paris enfin
tellement content sur le continent ce
que ça veut dire mais jean pierre
chevènement encore c'est quand même
l'homme du préfet bonnet c'est pas rien
donc ça fait beaucoup marqué les corses
je me souviens et ça a été le début d'un
long malentendu qui a persisté et d'un
éloignement d'une certaine façon entre
les deux hommes c'est ce que j'entends
alors quelle autonomie quelques chiffres
en tout cas un sondage publié dans corse
matin sur l'évolution du statut de la
corse d'abord parmi les les français
53% pour l'autonomie 35% pour
l'indépendance puisque l'institut a
sondé sur ces deux questions et pour les
résidents corses et les continentaux aux
origines corses
les chiffres ses 73% pour l'autonomie et
30 2%
pour l'indépendance alors quel est le
statut actuel de la corse jusqu'où
pourrait aller cette autonomie cette
autonomie havre avant de vous entendre
les uns et les autres là dessus j'aurais
quentin calme et nous nous rejoignent
bonsoir quentin peut-être pour détailler
un peu ce qu'est le statut actuel de la
corse alors déjà la corse a une place à
part dans nos institutions depuis les
lois defferre depuis mars 1980 2 qui lui
donne un statut particulier
l'instauration d'une assemblée de corse
avec une soixantaine d'élus qui sont
désignés au suffrage universel depuis
plusieurs lois ont même étendu les
compétences de l'exécutif local en 91 et
bien la collectivité territoriale de
corse est chargée de la promotion de
l'identité corse des compétences encore
élargie en 2002 et depuis le 1er janvier
2018 d'accord c'est une collectivité à
statut particulier c'est une conséquence
de la loi notre voter en 2015 avec et
bien les départements de la haute corse
et celui de la corse du sud qui ont font
que confuse est née avec la collectivité
territoriale de corse à la clé une
collectivité unique 5400 salariés un
budget de 1,2 milliard d'euros alors que
manque t-il cette collectivité corse et
bien en fait ces pouvoirs sont
contraints par l'article 72 de la
constitution je fais très attention à ce
que je dis maintenant que vous regardez
mes donc la cance elle a le même statut
en fait que d'autres collectivités
locales elle n'a pas sa propre place
dans le texte constitutionnel
et c'est donc une limite à l'adaptation
des textes de lois aux spécificités de
l'île les autonomistes aimerait la co
officialité de la langue corse ou encore
le statut de résident pour lutter contre
l'inflation des prix des logements sur
l'île et bien des mesures qui sont
totalement impossible tant que laïc cela
le statut de la corse il est défini dans
l'article 72 et alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis le début du
quinquennat
quentin autour de cette place de la
corse dans la constitution et bien en
fait ça peut paraître anecdotique mais
la place est bien de la corse dans la
constitution c'est son statut c'est
aussi son rapport à l'autorité de l'état
qui se joue l'article 72 défini
fonctionnement des collectivités locales
des communes des départements des
régions ou des collectivités à caractère
particulier donc la corse on a compris
ailier mais on voit d'autres cas de
figure l'article 74 reconnaît par
exemple la spécificité des outre mer
l'article 78 lui parle de toutes les
compétences de la nouvelle calédonie et
donc qui disposera de son propre
parlement de son propre exécutif même de
sa propre monnaie c'est donc d'air est
bien depuis 2010 est cet enjeu de la
place dans la constitution qui était en
cours de négociation avec les différents
responsables corse en visite ajaccio en
février 2018 le président de la
république est là et même fait un pas
vers cette demande on voit quelques
images lorsqu'ils se rencontrent pour la
première fois émue elle macron jeudi le
symbian et à jean guy talamoni et on va
voir que à ce moment là effectivement
miel macron il fait un pas vers eux on
écoute un
je suis favorable à ce que la course
puisse rentrer dans la constitution
parce que d'autres territoires de la
république y figurent et parce que c'est
une manière en effet de reconnaître son
identité et de l'ancrer dans la
république la refonte de l'article 72 de
la constitution que je proposerai au
parlement dans les prochaines semaines
on verra déjà des possibilités de
reconnaissance d'un droit à la
différenciation qui permettra à la
collectivité de corse d'être habilité à
adapter les lois et règlements régissant
l'exercice de ses compétences et à
obtenir le transfert de nouvelles
compétences voilà vous l'avez entendu
les films de référence à l'article 72
pas un article en dessous et en plus on
le sait depuis un deux puis 2018 la
révision constitutionnelle elle est au
point mort la faute à l affaire benalla
et aussi à une forme de résistance du
sénat et dans la dernière version du
gouvernement de cette révision
constitutionnelle c'est celle proposée
en 2019 la spécificité de la corse elle
faisait l'objet simplement d'un article
72 tirs et 5 mai donc sans réelle place
à part dans la constitution donc on
verra non elle s'il ya une volonté du
gouvernement déjà s'il relance la
révision constitutionnelle
bon ce qui va prendre du temps et en
fonction aussi de la place dans laquelle
est bien il placera à la corse dans la
constitution merci quand un pour tous
ces détails validé par benjamin je le
vois et c'était important paul toussaint
tu arrives ici on rentre maintenant dans
le dans le détail de cette autonomie
vous vous demandez quoi ça va elle peut
aller jusqu où l'autonomie vous réclame
mais il peut aller assez loin quand même
ce n'est pas une forte décentralisation
c'est une capacité pour la collectivité
de corse où la collectivité autonome de
course demain de prendre un certain
nombre de décisions par exemple fiscale
fiscale l'économique
le régal du réel le régalien est dans le
champ de régaliennes nom de l'autonomie
on nous demande pas frapper monnaie
encore moins d'avoir une armée mais
voilà certain nombre de compétences qui
aujourd'hui toutes les îles de
méditerranée sont beauté de ses
compétences la part dont j'ai une
question qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
dans la fiscalité par exemple corse etc
etc est-ce que quels impôts vous
crieriez ou quels impôts vous supprimiez
un exemple aujourd'hui qui touchent la
corse qui frappe la jeunesse corse c'est
une possibilité de se loger en corse
donc à ce niveau là on sait que nos
députés ont avancé un certain nombre de
propositions de loi à l'assemblée
nationale une une de ses compétences
seraient par exemple de taxer des
résidents secondaires benjamin morel oui
alors la question de l'autonomie en
réalité assez intéressante par rapport à
ce qu'on faisait tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que fondamentalement elle ne
renvoie pas de temps au-delà du symbole
à un corpus de compétences c'est-à-dire
que si on pense à l'autonomie
législatives aujourd'hui vous n'avez
qu'une collectivité en france qui vote
ses propres lois c'est la nouvelle
calédonie je pense qu'actuellement c'est
pas de monde c'est parce que demandent
les nationalistes corses en tout cas les
autonomistes là on va très très bon on
va dans un statut encore une fois qui
est un statut colonial donc on est sur
quelque chose qui vise beaucoup plus un
certain nombre de compétences très
particulières mais qui en fait sont
assez problématique prenez par exemple
les droits du résident
là on est sur quelque chose qui non
seulement est en compte est
anticonstitutionnelle mais ils posent
même des problèmes de conventionalité
est en fait renvoie à des problématiques
qui sont plus globale alors j'ai pas les
chiffres encore ce que vous prenez par
exemple c'est un sujet qui a percé au
moment des régionales en bretagne avec
justement les résidences secondaires
dans le morbihan etc or il s'avère que
la plupart des résidences secondaires
dans le morbihan appartiennent à des
rennais ou appartiennent à des nantais
est donc le problème voyez n'est pas
régional il est plus globale en réalité
aujourd'hui on a un problème de
répartition du patrimoine immobilier on
a un problème également et bien de
taxation des résidences secondaires et
la mesure qui est proposée par les
nationalistes corses en réalité est
d'intérêt public mais sur l'ensemble du
territoire probablement et donc on voit
qu'on a plusieurs problématiques qui se
télescopent et des problèmes politiques
économiques et sociales et des
problématiques politiques de l'autre
côté et au bout du compte qu'est-ce que
ça devient politiquement dans la bouche
de gérald darmanin dans le cadre de
l'indh un processus sous tension ça
devient le mot autonomie mais au bout du
compte lorsque vous aurez épluché toutes
ces problématiques
qu'est ce qu'il en restera à la fin du
processus de négociation à ce stade
c'est pas évident parce que encore une
fois droit du résident en conventionnel
problème au niveau du droit l'europe et
de huit doigts du l'ère open ça va être
la guerre allait faut peut-être pas
grand chose et donc une déception a rien
de chômage à fait d'accord c'est à dire
que là on dit autonomie on parle de
droit constitutionnel mais dans l'esprit
en tout cas des manifestants et dans
l'esprit des nationalismes vous direz si
je me trompe et d'ailleurs si un tel
savoir qu'on a un sénateur nationaliste
ici parce que oui c'est bien le signe
que j'ai eu des victoires électorales
sur quatre mascioli ce n'est pas rien et
bien dans l'esprit des manifestions
d'assises je pense que c'est
effectivement le statut de résident
c'est la co officialité de la langue
c'est à dire les documents
administratifs et le fait qu'on parle
aussi bien le camp français je me trompe
pas là et puis alors à mon avis encore
beaucoup plus compliqué non seulement le
rapprochement des prisonniers politiques
entre guillemets comme disent les
nationalistes mais aussi la mystique
c'est ça qu'on entendait dans les
manifestations donc on voit qu'on n'est
pas du tout là on est dans les symboles
et on n'est pas forcément dans le statut
dans ces manifestations est ce qu'on
entendait parler de crime d'état pour à
propos de la mort de divan
colonna
gretel français assassin c'est un solo
qui est à des années 90 comme après la
guerre entre nationalistes et donc il a
été ressuscité pour l'occasion et il a
évidemment beaucoup choqué sur le
continent c'était un vieux mais ce qui
moi ce qui m'a plus frappé c'est que
j'entendais une petite musique je pense
que cette agression même sait plus ce
qu'est la nation gérald darmanin mardi
c'est une tentative d'assassinât elle
est sidérante parce que ça dure une demi
minute parce que c'est l'agresseur lui
même qui prévient comment peut-on
imaginer comment la c8 minutes devant
des caméras sans intervention d'un
prisonnier comme celui qui arrive en
queue et puis après il ya eu beaucoup de
flou dans l' annonce on n'a pas su
exactement ce qui se passait on ne
comprenait rien ensuite il ya eu aucune
musique concrète personne n'a été blessé
depuis bien sûr il ya une commission qui
a été enfin n'y a pas eu de sanctions
immédiates donc ça a été très très
incompréhensible je pense pour
la corse d'autant plus incompréhensible
que quoi qu'on en dise rapprocher les
prisonniers c'est à dire que ça fait
quand même depuis 98 maintenant 24 ans
qui sont en prison pour des détenus qui
avaient été eux aussi qu'ils avaient
commis des crimes comme comme par
exemple je pense avec son direct etc le
statut idée vraiment le l'administration
pénitentiaire avait été beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus apaisante avait réussi là
où il faut pas oublier que c'est le
parquet qui a fait appel de la décision
de rapprocher de la demande de
rapprochement en corse de déco deux
membres du commando erignac donc tout ça
il y avait une forme d'incompréhension
réel en corse et donc état français
assassin effectivement ça réussit cette
ça ça a réveillé une vieille génération
c'est la première génération pas sûr
la guérilla 75 qui est venu dans les
manifestations avec les très jeunes
manifestants qui eux n'avaient aucune
idée quasiment qui était claude erignac
en faillite est à ce point il n'y a pas
cette conscience de
je crois pas me tromper mais yvan
colonna il été mis de côté c'était plus
un héros toutes les affiches tout les
détails sur les rochers au bord de la
route la rue gloria ati vent s'était
effacée depuis longtemps il y avait de
la mousse dessus depuis très longtemps
ça avait disparu tout ça et tout d'un
coup c'était mal à 7,7 cet incident
beaucoup plus qu'un incident qui est et
qui a été vraiment reçu avec beaucoup
d'incompréhension encore ses biens a mis
le feu aux poudres alors le directeur de
jeu vous donner la parole tout de suite
là dessus mais j'aurais qu'on entende le
la réaction du directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire il était
auditionné aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale il parle des des tice alors
les ti ce sont les détenus pour
terrorisme islamique on écoute de ne
plus avec tout le respect que je vous
dois monsieur le député
et votre mandat laissez vous laisser
dire que l'illustration pénitentiaire
ne prend pas en compte le danger que
représentent les tice nous faisons le
maximum
j'assume si ce maximum ne produit pas
toujours les effets escomptés je
l'assumé totalement
mais je peux vous dire que la
mobilisation de tous les fonctionnaires
pénitentiaires parfois au péril de leur
vie et total notamment sur ce secteur
paul toussaint parigi vous avez avec
d'autres sénateurs ont envoyé une lettre
à gérard larcher on va l'avoir
d'ailleurs ce sur nos écrans vous
demandez quoi une commission denquête
l'ouverture d'une commission d'enquêté
au sénat tout à fait aujourd'hui il
reste comme un flou assez impressionnant
sur la tentative d'assassinât sur sur
yvan colonnes lorsqu'on apprend qu'il ya
300 caméras dans cette prison de arles
quand on sait qu'il ya 185 employés dans
cette prison qui a des employés avec un
statut d ps la question se pose quand
même comment est il possible que deux
prisonniers se retrouvent dans la même
endroit
et avec ce qui ce qui a suivi cette
atrocité et cela pendant aujourd'hui le
temps varie en a pas deux trois minutes
au départ on a parlé de 8 noeuds tenant
on est à onze
ça devient inquiétant pour la sécurité
dans les prisons mais vous vous parlez
de quoi de défaillance ou deux
vous allez plus loin que ça et
effectivement il ya des défaillances et
ça nous on ne peut pas les cacher quand
on compte quand on on écoute ce matin
l'audition et contre
derrière vos mots il ya un peu et il ya
eu un laisser faire ce que je veux dire
dans tous les cas nous avions alerté à
plusieurs reprises
le cas des prisonniers du commando
erignac c'est pas la première fois qu'il
ya une agression
alain ferrand bien fait l'objet d'une
agression dans sa prison il ya quelques
quelques années à coup de boules de
pétanque donc que nous avions demandé à
plusieurs reprises nous et nous sommes
allés visiter la prison de poissy et
nous avons à plusieurs reprises demander
le rapprochement de ces prisonniers
parce que on sentait qu'ils étaient en
difficulté est en danger voilà une fois
de plus nous n'avons pas été entendus
mais voilà ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
mathieu cette question du rapprochement
des des des prisonniers corses ce que ce
qu'on appelle les dps détenu
particulièrement surveillé faut pas
oublier que voilà ce dont on parle c'est
là la mort l'assassinât d'un préfet donc
j'ai chaque ça justifie le fait qu on
les maintient en prison aussi van sant
est loin de la corse mais bon tout
l'argument d'aider des soutiens d'yvan
colonna c'est une décision politique une
sorte de vengeance de revanche hausse de
2,2 de l'état du corps préfectoral pour
interdire et sanctionner yvan colonnes
pour son geste il ya une charge
émotionnelle très forte faut il le
rappeler je le préfet erignac se fait
assassiner quand il après avoir déposé
son épouse on alors un concert enfin
j'avais parmi nos téléspectateurs et
gras qui se souviennent pas de cette
histoire il faut le dire aussi il se
fait se prend trois balles dans le dos
une dans la nuque et devant la tête
et et ça a été un traumatisme à l'époque
un traumatisme pour évidemment toute
l'administration pour tout le corps
préfectoral mais aussi pour la france
parce que j'ai en ont tué un
représentant de l'état comme ça pour ce
qu'il représentait plus que pour ceux
qui l'avaient fait ou dit parce que
c'est pas quelqu'un qui s'était illustré
particulièrement par par des
provocations même si évidemment rien ne
justifie jamais d'assassiner un homme et
cette charge symbolique elle résonne
aujourd'hui en partie évidemment dans
l'opinion corse et chez les jeunes
corses qui redécouvre peut-être ils vont
colonnes comme ariane à rien de nous le
disait et qu'on essaie de vue du
continent un mois je n'y suis pas mais
on a l'impression que ce qu'on essaie de
nous le faire passer pour un prisonnier
politique une forme de nelson mandela
corse d'une certaine façon alors que
c'est un assassin de droit commun c'est
une première chose et puis une charge
symbolique aussi dans la façon dont
l'exécutif géré cette affaire ce matin
avec un mail au ministre de l'intérieur
qui tout à son désir d'essayer de dire
non non l'état n'y est pour rien ce
n'est pas un crime d'état parce que
évidemment il faut aussi dire que dans
cette semaine dans ces manifestations il
y avait cette idée peut-être d'un
complot de laisser-faire qu'on avait
laissé ou fait assassiner enfin fait
agresser ils vont en colonne en prison
comment il se défendra malin ce matin il
dit bah non c'est un crime de terrorisme
islamiste et il arrive à yvan colonnes
ce qui est arrivé à ce mail pâtit alors
là moi j'ai trouvé ça profondément
choquant je viens chaque histoire est
différente comparaison est par exemple
et là au nom de parce qu ils inquiets
c'était une question de blasphème et
l'autre parce qu'il avait enseigné la
liberté de blasphème on rapproche ces
ces deux éléments moi je trouve ça
particulièrement
inappropriée et ce qu'on a le timbre est
ce que ça vous choque que ces détenus
soient restés n'est pas été j'avais dit
rapatriés en corse où est ce que
finalement c'est simplement une
application du droit non je crois qu'il
ya plusieurs aspects c'est-à-dire lancer
une application du droit en soit le
droit n'a pas été tordu mais il aurait
pu être interprété différemment il
aurait pu être interprété différemment
et on peut se retrouver sur un certain
nombre de points là dessus c'est à dire
que vous avez en fait trois enjeux il ya
la résistance de la préfectorale ça a
été évoqué en effet on est dans un crime
ça a été dit qui est un crime qui a
choqué la france parce que
fondamentalement il est choquant c'est
la première fois qu'en tuant un préfet
de l'autre côté et comme c'est choquant
de
d'imaginer ou de voir quand on passait
encore des détails et héros il en
évoquant
la corse est connue quarante mille
personnes après l'assassinât qu'il faut
écouter emmanuel macron lors de son
premier discours en corse et puis
ensuite quand il revient pour le grand
débat ça souvent été oublié où il
demande aux nationalistes de faire on va
dire leur aggiornamento sur yvan colonna
mais pas que vous avez a lieu à l'iut de
corte un amphithéâtre s'appelle
acquaviva qu'est le nom d'un militant
flnc morts au combat donc il ya un
problème également c'est à dire que vous
avez aujourd'hui en corse des militants
fln c'est qu'ils sont héroïsé qui on
donne le nom de bâtiments publics le
préfet le jour ce jour là n'a pas voulu
être là à l'inauguration
donc il ya aujourd'hui vraiment pour les
natios un aggiornamento qui doit être
fait sur tout ça et qui se ressent
aujourd'hui dans la rue c'est à dire
vous pouvez pas d'un côté héroïsé
pendant des années ensuite vous étonnez
que la jeunesse est bien manifeste en
disant eh bien oui c'est un héros donc
là est un sujet ensuite en effet il ya
eu des résistances de la préfectorale
est en effet il ya probablement eu la
part du gouvernement une volonté de
garder des billes dans les négociations
parce que ben voilà c'est à dire que
dans un processus de négociation où
c'était une revendication des
nationalistes c'est purement cynique
mais probablement je n'avance pas et il
une possibilité que le gouvernement
garde civile a donc dans le procès un
procès mais négociation et c'est pas
forcément quelque chose d'heureux
ensuite vous avez des problèmes de
sécurité malgré tout à la prison de
borgo et là qu'ils ont pu être avancé et
qui probablement aurait malgré tout et
pu être traitées en amont mais on veut
dire que la prison n'était pas forcément
adapté
on a un jour évoluer ps on aurait
peut-être pu lever se situe dps dont
débattent et 200 en coulisses mais il y
avait il ya quand même un certain nombre
de problèmes de sécurité à borgo et
c'est qu'elles auraient pu être les
éventuels complexité l'exemple
complicité et ce qui aurait pu avoir un
téléguidage de réseaux nationalistes
c'était ce qui était craint par une
partie de l'état est ce que ces craintes
justifiées de ne pas lever ce statut
peut être pas mais c'est également des
craintes qu'ils font entendre pour tous
un pari gs que effectivement
ce qui s'est passé pour yvan colonna est
en effet extrêmement choquant et le fait
d'avoir une commission d enquête
parlementaire est aujourd'hui nécessaire
c'est à dire que s'il ya bien un une
fonction du parlement en matière de
contrôle des politiques publiques qui
mérite une commission denquête c'est
justement ce type de dysfonctionnement
administratif et là il faudrait qu en
effet se prononcer au sénat mais
également à l'assemblée
yvan colonna pour vous c'est quoi dans
l'identité corse
dans quelques mois yvan colonna d'abord
c'est une personne que j'ai côtoyés
avant avant l'assassinât du préfet
erignac cette un militant nationaliste
qui croyait beaucoup
la lutte du peuple corse
il était accusé du crime du préfet
erignac ne jamais reconnu
aujourd'hui un symbole bpt.un fait
partie de
ces cons on a du mal à entendre le fait
que ce soit des prisonniers politiques
pour nous ce sont des prisonniers
politiques
effectivement monsieur même si les
choses ont été reprises
aujourd'hui yvan colonna je crois il ya
de la justice est passée 1 lorsque
l'assassinât du préfet erignac a eu lieu
les corses sont descendus dans la rue
ils ont dénoncé cet acte
moi je crois que la justice ait dépassé
aujourd'hui on était dans une phase
alors je ne sais pas comment on trouve
et quel terminologie mais de
réconciliation entre entre entre entre
l'état et la corse est en fête
est arrivé ce drame qui fait que bon
tout et tout et tout tout les rangs tout
est remis en cause mais je voudrais
rajouter quelque chose quand même parce
que on a l'impression que c'est
seulement ce qui est arrivé à la prison
d'arles qui fait que la course
aujourd'hui
se révoltent c'est pas tout à fait que
ça vient de passer quand même
certains moments avec un préfet encore
ski qui confond et qui a confondu son
son statut de préférer que celui d'un
gouverneur qui a taxé la collectivité de
course sur une amende d'un marché public
mal passé mais avec avec bien sûr l'état
aussi à la manoeuvre qui repartit en
repositionnant de 10 millions d'euros
les caisses de la cdc vous comprenez
bien que ça lui a fait du mal et puis
qui est allé retoqué le règlement
intérieur de cette même collectivité qui
avait décidé à l'unanimité
des partis qui la représente d'utiliser
la langue corse aussi lors des débats
donc c'est quand même beaucoup de choses
qui ont été à un moment donné a cumulé
qui ont fait qu'aujourd'hui avant
d'aller la pression s'est déchiré dans
la rue avec avec beaucoup de jeunes vous
l'avez dit rien le chemin c'est assez
assez sacem moi ça m'a surpris quand
j'ai vu les premières images des
manifestations vont peut-être pas parce
que vous connaissez très bien la cance
mais qu'est ce qui explique cette
mobilisation cette radicalisation de la
jeunesse corse bien c'est vrai que
rappeler des épisodes précédents même si
c'est un peu compliqué c'est important
parce qu'il y avait une véritable
tension avant l'arrivée du nouveau
préfet avec le préfet des précédents il
ya une telle histoire le drapeau qui a
disparu fin mode et des tables
d'engueulades effectivement au sein de
l'hémicycle de la collectivité de corse
qui rassemble qui faisait penser à celle
des années la fin des années 90 où il y
avait eu au moment du préfet bonnet de
grosse blinde de grosses prises de bec
effet je pense que cette cette
génération là elle a élu comme d'autres
gilles simeoni
lll attendu nouveau jeudi après tout on
a voté à deux tiers on est pour un
autonomiste qu'est ce qu'il se passe
elle a vu une série de petites ce cas là
je vais être des humiliations et puis
voilà il ya un effet générationnel comme
tout d'un coup
on s'est dit bon bah ils font rien ça
bouge pas on reprend le flambeau et
c'est vrai qu'ils sont très motivés et à
tel point que à chaque fois j simonis
obligé de calmer cette jeunesse il va
lui-même à la fac de corte dans les
amphis pour essayer de voilà de faire
baisser d'un ton le monde a publié une
tribune de la présidente de l'assemblée
de corse qui disait qu'elle a elle
réclamé elle a réclamé lundi pour les
prisonniers c'est parce qu'elle était
pressée par ses jeunes et étudiants et
c'est la première fois qu'on les voit
effectivement si une nouvelle génération
il ya eu celle voilà qui a aujourd'hui
70 ans et qui étaient là dont les rues
pour essayer de calmer justement ses
fils ou petit fils de voilà des derniers
mohicans 20 nationaliste et c'est ça qui
était frappant c'est qu'on avait sauté
une génération ils étaient tous là mais
là les plus vieux qu'elle met les plus
jeunes parce que c'est vrai que ça
ressemblait quand même à d une sorte de
guérilla urbaine les combats de rue les
bombes agricoles ça fait beaucoup de
bruit oui j'ai eu aussi en présentant
des forces de l'ordre qui a été roué de
coups celui que je préfère nouveau
préfet de corse a géré ça je dois dire
assez bien parce que c'est vrai qu'il
peut la première manifestation pendant
trois heures on voyait la police qui se
parlaient des charges comme ça ils n'ont
pas bougé et puis aussi tout seul il
faut pas oublier que ça a commencé aussi
par ce paquebot qui est arrivé à ajaccio
défense de l'ordre et le préfet moi je
pense a bien fait ils étaient en train
de discuter avec ses syndicats nationale
ici là il a fait repartir des forces de
l'ordre parce qu'il savait que c'était
le début d'un embrasement il a très bien
compris oui sauf que les forces de
l'ordre ils ont dit après qu'ils
n'étaient pas assez nombreux je suis bon
c'est quand même un a raison
je pense pas dit que je sais bien mais
ça c'est bien vu c'est également un lieu
d'embrasement et vieux effectivement est
un terme qui avait publié le monde qui
montrait que les forces de police
n'étaient pas assez nombreuses encore un
benjamin morel pourrait comprendre c'est
encore une fois sur sur la jeunesse
corse il faut se pencher sur le système
éducatif et sur la place peut-être deux
nationalisme des nationalistes dans 30
mn en partie ce quelque chose qu a
notamment bien analysé jérôme fourquet
dans un livre qu'il avait fait il ya
quelques années sur la corse et qui
montrait qu'en réalité il ya un tournant
au milieu des années 2000 en réalité en
2000 au moment justement le processus de
matignon ex ha vous avez une
politisation et une radicalisation de la
société corse dont aujourd'hui les
fruits en termes de jeunesse maariv à
l'âge adulte et à partir de là et bien
rentrer dans un processus qui est un
processus est un processus qu'on connaît
assez bien on a connu par exemple ça en
catalogne en catalogne ça c'est
intéressant de voir l'évolution de la de
la droite catalane aise c'est à dire que
vous avez une génération plutôt
d'autonomistes qui forment une jeune
génération sur ses idées régionaliste
assez radicale et au bout d'un moment
qui est dépassé c'est à dire que au
moment de la crise du milieu des années
2010 à 2015 et bien la jeunesse catalane
de la droite catalanes demandent aux
autonomistes devenir indépendantisme et
la vieille garde est obligé de reculer
au bout d'un moment et finit par entrer
dans un processus de radicalisation et
de bras de fer avec l'état espagnol vous
les connaissez ce crise en
partie en ces temps partiel ce qui est
en train de se passer en corse étaient
les hôtes en 2000 et cantine quand ils
ont obtenu l'autonomie pas forcément ses
dépens alors ça c'est ce qu'ils sont eux
qui ont la main ça pour le coup c'est
quelque chose qu'on analyse assez bien
en sciences politiques c'est à dire
qu'on voit dans les différents pays
européens qui ont mis en place pas tant
une décentralisation approfondies ni
même un fédéralisme mais
décentralisation différencier et le
moment où vous différencier les statuts
vous avez deux phénomènes qui se
produisent d'abord une fois que
l'autonomie et obtenu l' et bien les
autonomistes en plus grand-chose à
promettre c'est à dire que à part le
logiciel gestionnaire le grand récit
nationaliste à ses clients qui le
portent sont les indépendantistes et
très rapidement ils sont supplantés par
les indépendantistes est le premier
mouvement ensuite vous créer un
mouvement de mimétisme entre
collectivités
regardez ce qui s'est passé en grande
bretagne c'est assez intéressant en 1997
d'évolution là le pays de galles a un
statut qui est moins favorable que celui
de l'ecosse les gallois disent non nous
on a un statut à l'écossais s'ils
obtiennent en 2011 en 2012 des écossais
disent qu'on n'est pas comme légal one
on veut un statut qui est meilleure et
l'obtiennent en 2012 et gallois disent
non c'est pas possible les écossais
disent non plus ils nous suivent
derrière nous on veut l'indépendance est
là aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on voit aux
mines haut possible et c'est le danger
c'est à dire que si vous regardez
aujourd'hui quel est le modèle frédéric
bierry en alsace c'est la corse si vous
regardez quel est le modèle des bretons
qui ont été visitées frédéric bierry
lors des régionales c'est l'alsace quel
est le modèle de la corse aujourd'hui
c'est en effet les collectivités de
l'article 74 et c'est là vous avez un
danger profond on a analysé dans
l'ensemble des autres pays d'europe
allez avoue mode la conclusion mais je
sais dit réagir paul toussaint paris moi
je crois que que gilles c'est bien là
était clair je ne sais mais on est un
autonomiste et non pas indépendantiste
je crois que c'est eux c'est encore lui
l'enfer de la corse bien sûr c'est
l'homme fort de la course est impossible
de penser qu'aujourd'hui jc m'éloigner
ne soit plus dans le jeu politique c'est
pas possible ça celle ci vient dé
l'homme fort de la course il a démontré
tout seul qui pouvait avoir une majorité
absolue sur son nom et c'est la première
fois que cela s'est passé en corse
ensuite géré je ne peux pas entendre que
les que les jeunes course se soit
radicaliser moi j'étais au coeur des
événements
alors on fait beaucoup de botton coup de
bruit effectivement il ya eu deux
manifestations qui ont qui à un moment
donné va coûter sont terminés la rue un
peu de la rue a parlé moi ces jeunes
courent cela ce sont 10 est pour les
gilets jaunes qui ont nos clients
saccagé l'arc de triomphe on a parlé de
gilet jaune à radicaliser le sang séché
les cours quand des gens en dessous du
raisonnable
on est là pour les accompagner et moi je
prends le temps de parler que ce sont
des violents que son de la racaille
comme j'ai entendu sont des résistants
des gens qui veulent aider des jeunes
qui est qui qui sont critiqués kick qui
sont aujourd'hui sanaa dira-t-il et
hérésie la violence des résistants oui
pour moi je verse pas de radicaliser ça
veut dire radicaux moi ça m'a frappé
j'ai vu des très jeunes filles qui
tenait la banderole etc je n'ai pas du
tout c'est pas une critique elle était
très politisé très politisée et très
radical
c'est de la colère c'est de la colère on
a énuméré tout ce qui s'est passé avant
on veut dire c'est pas possible il ya un
moment donné je vois même au sénat il ya
un mépris sur la question corse un déni
de démocratie et un moment donné je dire
bye s'exprime dans la rue à lui très
vite un dernier mot ce qui est vrai en
tout cas c'est que je pense qu'il ya dix
ans un mot comme ça prononcé autonomie
en une de corse-matin serait mis en émoi
toute la classe politique française et
aujourd'hui ça quand même changer
effectivement je suis d'accord il ya
souvent un mépris à l'égard de la grèce
mais là je trouve que quand même ça se
passe de manière beaucoup plus calme que
l'on aurait pu imaginer avec un tel mot
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat sans